[Music]
foreign
from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality host of The Rachel Cruz show
co-host of the smart money happy hour my
daughter is my co-host today open phones
a triple eight eight two five five two
two five that's triple eight eight two
five five two two five Chase starts this
hour in Seattle hi Chase welcome to the
Ramsay show
hey Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
uh just a quick question for you today
uh I recently got on an engagement and
I'm trying to figure out how to handle
the budget after the fact
wow I'm sorry that's a that's a big
decision
yeah it was it's been really hard and
yeah
um you know I think it's one of the
hardest things I've ever done but will
be one of the best things that I've ever
done at the same time
um what happened before we get the money
my biggest thing is I just I just want
to make sure I do the right thing uh I
was just having doubts Dave
and I shouldn't have doubts about the
woman that I want to marry and so I
don't think that was fair to her and I
don't think he was fair to me either and
things ended great you know it was a
very mature uh decision on both our
parts wow
um and now you know now we're trying to
handle the budget and so I'm trying to
figure out how to do that and how to do
this the right way and so find that
closure and you know just do the right
thing give us the details what's the uh
what are the Bill Bill's outstanding
that need to be covered and who thinks
they ought to cover what
yeah so that's where it gets interesting
so the bills paid just for the wedding
so far was it totals five thousand three
hundred and sixty dollars
and when I reached out to them to try to
figure out hey how do we handle this
um they said okay well the dress that we
purchased is non-refundable and we're
going to keep that so we'll subtract
that from the total of 5 360.
who is they
uh that it would be her and her parents
oh okay
yeah okay so you the Bill's already paid
are fifty three hundred dollars
okay all right
and the dress she said is not for
non-refundable so she's gonna just keep
it so what how much was that
the dress was two thousand okay so you
have 3 300 left
yep exactly and they think that it is
more than reasonable that I cover the
remaining 3300 on my own
[Music]
um
so yeah do I what country were the one
that broke up exactly
um
what do you make
I make 78 000. how much money do you
have
enough to cover it how much money do you
um
maybe five thousand bucks
okay how old are you
23 years old wow
what's Your Gut say Chase what would
make you feel
right yeah
um let's see
I think there's two truths to this a lot
of me just wants to no there's only one
truth but there's two viewpoints yeah
right a lot of me just wants to pay it
and be done with it and you know that
way they they don't have anything
negative that they could say about me in
the situation
um it would you know it would I don't
think it's about the money at this point
and I think it's more of just kind of a
jab at me and um
you know I'm trying to pay for a
master's degree right now too so that
would be tough but at the same time it's
just money
and so you know if 3 300 bucks is what
it takes for
just to be over with and for both of us
to find that closure I think so be it
but you know I don't know if it's worth
the time to try to negotiate and like
hey maybe we should just split this in
half you know
yeah
um here's the thing I would not make the
decision based on what they think or
what they're going to say about you in
the future yes yes okay I would make the
decision about what is the ethical
correct thing to do from your position
and whatever their opinion is is just
going to be their opinion
like it or not okay but you can't buy
their let me just tell you you break up
with my daughter while you're engaged
you're probably not going to give it
ever give me enough money to make me
really love you
think about it right so I mean think
that you're just not going to buy that
right
sorry that's okay I'm not saying you did
the wrong thing but I mean just having
trying to get trying to have level of
con of controlling what they think about
you through this is not is not why you
would do that should not be your
motivation to your point because you
can't control like you could pay this
and then you could hear a year later oh
yeah some family friend was like golly
Heap Chase really screwed over and I'm
not you know they're all mad like they
could still do that and you have paid it
you know what I'm saying so like you
can't control what they think or feel
about you in the future sometimes also a
thing that helps me with ethics is to go
way out in the future and say like okay
you're 23. when you're 73
and you're thinking back on this
what's going to make you feel right
I can tell you I can tell you by the way
pay it I have no idea
I'd pay it and I'll pay you chase
because I think there's a level of um
again it's not a it's not a right or
wrong thing and I feel like you in your
case you made the right call for you
which I think is extremely courageous to
break off an engagement I'm like that's
that's really after the very first
purchase yeah I mean like you're in the
middle of playing I'm like oh my gosh
you even have the wherewithal to be like
I'm gonna I gotta end this so it's not a
knock on you chase I think you did a
very courageous decision but I also
think because of that decision there are
these dominoes that have played out that
have in a tune of thirty three hundred
dollars and I think there's a level of
just owning it do you know what I mean
of like Yep this was my call to do this
and to end it even though it was the
right call for me uh but because of that
I'm gonna
take care of what I need to for myself
to resolve and take ownership of that
decision and move forward with my life
and I think this thirty three hundred
dollars is a representation
of you taking ownership and moving
forward and if I was in your shoes I
would write the check and I'd do it for
all of those reasons that Rachel said
and you will never look back and regret
it yeah
right you're not doing it out of
weakness you're not I've found her
cheating on you or like you know there
was some other big Dynamic to this
formula then I would be like
girlfriend like you gotta you know what
I'm saying but but she's cheating on you
her parents pay the bill you get she get
they get nothing but that's different
you're the guy broke the contract here
not by cheating but I mean you you had a
deal we had a deal there's a ring on the
finger and you decided I'm not doing
that deal and the cost of getting out of
the deal is pay the bills so that's
that's one reason the other reason is I
can promise you from having done stuff
like this in the past it it relieves up
at the moment you're doing it it's like
this sucks I don't want to do this but
you will never look back and go 20 years
from now I wish I had negotiated with
those people you'll never go back and
say that the 40 year old you the 60 year
old you will never go back and go oh I
really did I really messed that up I
should have screwed them over would your
uh uh would your viewpoint change at all
if all it was 50
down and all this stuff and they want
him to pay like you don't mean does the
amounts
change the weight of it makes it harder
to make the decision and I would have to
weigh in at that point
the length of time let me just tell you
if you sign up for fifty thousand
dollars worth of stuff it wasn't him
signing up for all that that would have
been like her and her mom signing up for
all that so I probably would have put
some weight on them this is a very
reasonable yes amount yep and yeah and
and they're deducting the dress from it
they're they're trying yes yes yeah and
so I'm I'm you'll just have no regrets
live a life where you have sleep with
your head on the pillow it's that simple
this
is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
buying a home is one of the biggest
decisions of your life you need a
partner like Churchill Mortgage
Churchill is one of the highest rated
lenders in the country and their Ramsay
trusted because they do what's right for
you Churchill works with you to build a
mortgage the Ramsay way one that doesn't
bust your budget sets you up for
financial success and helps you get out
of debt faster go to
churchillmortgage.com today and get
started
[Music]
foreign
personality number one best-selling
author and a co-host if you haven't
checked it out with George Campbell
smart money happy hour is one of the
biggest hits on Ramsey Network right now
so on the Ramsay networks it's a great
podcast a lot of fun in the afternoon
these two cut up and carry on George is
the king of snark and uh you'll you'll
like hanging out with the two of them
smart money happy hour be sure and do
that when it comes to this show we need
your help would you subscribe please
would you follow push the follow button
click it click it click it and I'll
leave us a five-star review one star
reviews are not helpful if you don't
like the show quit listening but uh hey
it's pretty simple move on and but
otherwise leave us a five-star review
we'd love to have that thank you it's a
big help on the old algorithms on the
internet pushes the show forward other
people get to learn about it and all of
that kind of stuff and of course you can
share the show share the link click the
share a button on however it is you're
consuming it whether it's Spotify or
apple whatever it is oh and by the way
you could share which talk radio station
you're listening to that would work too
or maybe you're a YouTuber I don't care
no maybe I'm the YouTuber you're the
Watcher on YouTube I'm just a YouTuber
now Rachel that's kind of like baloney
I'm down today open phones here triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jonathan's in Washington D.C hey
Jonathan how are you
hi sir thank you so much for taking my
call Rachel it's a pleasure to speak
with you thank you Jonathan how can we
help
yeah
um so I'm in a bit of a predicament
um in January I moved my family up from
Central Virginia to the southern
Maryland outside of DC uh for a
fantastic job that God just kind of
seemed to have fallen to my laps
um and then two weeks ago I was laid off
so that sucks you went from yes so we
have now gone from making more money
than I thought I would make in my life
to literally only getting the disability
I claim from the Air Force
um and so we are on baby step two trying
to work down our debt as soon as I lost
my job we started contacting all our
creditors and explaining the situation
and everything's been great
um everyone's been very accommodating
which was thank God because I was not
expecting that
um with the exception of today my wife's
credit card company basically said we're
not going to lower your monthly payment
unless you go through a consolidation
loan
um and so they connected her with an
organization called navicorp not
familiar with them don't know anything
about them you don't need to do that
okay tell them to bite your ankle
okay
no they're not in charge they're a
stupid credit card company you're in
charge
so what were you making
I was making 88 000 a year at the the
dream job that you just got laid off
yes sir doing what
I am a public relations specialist
okay what happened how did they screw up
so bad they move a family from out of
state only to lay them off
that's pretty freaking ridiculous
um what was told to me is that I was not
meeting their expectations for quality
of work
okay wow ouch and I can only vouch for
myself so much you know I have a degree
to go with it and seven and a half years
of experience doing public relations to
the Air Force
and that's all I know you know I have my
opinion but I don't think it's worth it
doesn't matter now
their opinion counts because they own
the place they can do what they want
okay so you're looking how long have you
been looking
and literally since the day I talked
later no winning was that
uh that was on May 3rd
okay just a couple weeks ago okay yes
sir all right
for me
um it's okay you know there have been a
couple things that have have kind of
drawn out but one was in Dallas Texas
and they want they would want me there
day one and I don't know if I can move
my family halfway across the country
having just moved them upwards
um oh you can
if you're choosing Dallas over D.C in
about 13 seconds I make that decision
I I and I believe you and I agree there
I just neither my wife and I through
prayer have felt comfortable with it and
so we're just trying to trying to seek
God's will as much as we can there
um and then been applying for as many
things as I possibly can
um had an interview this morning but
unfortunately it's sort of a different
sort of communication uh more of like a
dispatcher Communicator than a telling
people what's going on in the world
Communicator
um but yeah if you know anyone who's
hiring for a uh public relations person
with 12 years of experience and a
college degree
Jonathan in Washington D.C is looking
okay so
selfish I apologize that's okay it's all
good
um
how much money you got in the bank
we have about sixteen hundred dollars in
our credit account in our Yeah in our um
does your wife work
she does not know she um has gone off
work to stay he's got a side hustle
going yet
I am actually I was about to throw in a
tie and go out to our local warehouse
store and uh apply for an in-person
interview yep yep take all you can get
right now get some money coming in for
food I was yeah I was gonna say the side
hustle and then Jonathan honestly and
it's not a
long-term thing but I'm like but the
remote work place is still booming like
people are still doing so much remote
you know if you can find a company that
maybe you're not there long term but it
at least gets you into
a career that you don't have to move
your family because you guys aren't
comfortable with that right now and then
it's kind of settle into something and
then and then maybe in a year you look
for something else you know but finding
something quickly I think is going to be
the key and it may not be your passion
it may not be everything that you love
it may not be a company you love but you
guys got 1600 bucks and I'm like you
know what can you plug into very quickly
uh the side hustle will be that that
bridge but
I mean I think about health insurance I
mean there's just a lot there's a lot
there and so you you want to be able to
to have something fast and I think
because of the urgency it may not be a
thing that you absolutely are passionate
about and love but it's getting what you
need for your family at the for the time
and then and then maybe that other
opportunity comes and yeah and you have
the bandwidth to be able to
do that how old are you
I will be 34 in June okay thank you for
your service by the way
um let me give you uh something to pray
over and think about
it would be normal in your situation
because you felt like God LED you to
this and obviously you didn't
um and so sometimes in my life in my
spiritual walk I have confused uh last
night's pizza with the Holy Spirit or he
did and he's teaching and there's a
lesson for Jonathan I mean it could be
it could be but it didn't it short term
it doesn't look good right so sometimes
I thought something was God and it
wasn't is all I'm saying
um yeah and so what happens with that
and getting fired for something you know
you're good at it shakes your confidence
if you're a normal human being at least
it did mine when those kinds of things
have happened to me and so
um uh I I would just pray about the
Dallas move as to whether uh ask God for
a real clear guidance as to whether
that's his spirit this is troubling you
or just you're not feeling confident
right now and so nothing that looks
risky feels okay nothing that has a high
rate of change feels okay because you're
at a low Point emotionally I'm not
saying one way or another I'm not just
declaring that that's God I don't know
what God's will is for this and you for
you but um but I am seeking peace and I
want that peace to come from him and
from strength not from
avoiding anything that looks like risk
after I just got my lights punched out
yeah so just just kind of lean into that
and you guys make sure that's what it is
because
um with everything that's going on I
liked the sound of the Dallas thing just
looking in from the outside now I've met
you a whole three minutes ago so I'm not
an expert on Jonathan's life or what's
good for you don't don't misunderstand
but out of everything you put in the mix
here that sounded the most fun of
anything you brought up
um and obviously I'm I I mean I like
that City for a lot of different reasons
but uh for opportunity for you and all
kinds of things as far as PR goes DC the
pr stuff is much darker it's much more
oriented around politics and
social issues and those kinds of things
rather than doing PR in a business
setting or a Ministry setting not as
much of that in DC as there is in Dallas
so just something to think about and no
income tax in Texas so there you go yeah
there you go yeah that's fun there's
yeah I could just go on and on but I'm
I'm Gonna Leave it right there I think
Dave we're going to go into the
commercial break on time this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
yeah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and next week's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
20 plus years ago I started teaching
Financial Peace University with a bad
suit and an overhead projector and a
hotel Ballroom we would break up and
have small group discussions after I
would teach a lesson in those days the
lessons there were 13 of them and we
taught them every other week so you were
with me for 26 weeks it was
579 dollars to go through
the first four people that went through
cried a lot because I'm mean because I
love you so much I'm gonna make you do
this stuff all four of them are
millionaires now
that's a lot of years ago and it works
now 10 million people have gone through
this class sitting with coordinators
that are a lot nicer than me who have a
discussion with you after you go through
one of the only nine lessons now it's
much sweeter now it's much easier now
but it is still a proven system well
Dave I can find everything you teach in
that on YouTube yeah there's 400 YouTube
clips that you could go through that
have FPU stuff in them if you want to
wander around in that for three or four
years and try to figure that out you can
oh by the way none of this I invented
it's all common sense you could have
just done that
live on less than you make you don't
need us at all but if you really want to
do the right thing and do this stuff
right down the line and do the system
that is proven and has an average of an
eight thousand dollar turnaround in the
first 90 days if you go through the
lessons at least one a week
and you sit with your coordinator online
or in person and are held accountable
and encouraged if you're struggling and
scared we're all been there and if you
do all of that that there's an eight
thousand dollar turnaround an average of
fifty three hundred dollars in debt paid
off in the first 90 days and a 2700
Savings in the first 90 days that's the
average across 10 million people and
some of those people did nothing
and some of them were extremely
successful so all of that's going on and
you could join Rachel's class Rachel is
closed is it closed they're not letting
people in no but you can uh delony's
starts next week I think so John deloney
can call now mine is closed and Jade's
just closed then too yes yep
yeah two weeks in too far yeah okay so
um Rachel's got a very popular class
Jade had a very has a very popular class
but Coleman deloney you can still get it
on and George Campbell you can still get
it and Eddie yes so go to fpu.com if you
want to do that or just
ramseysolutions.com I mean you don't
have to go to the celebrity coordinator
Ramsey personality one if you don't want
to if you want to go to a regular class
at your church that's cool or you want
to just join a virtual class and one of
our other people are a coordinator
that's fine but you need the you need
the people in your life to make sure
you're doing the system because if
you'll submit yourself to this proven
system you're going to have the results
it works doesn't it yo yeah uh we had
week we're on week two with my class and
so on Monday we went through
the debts no no I guess it was on no it
was on Wednesday it was last Wednesday
gosh it's been almost week and uh three
people there live got on the audio on
the zoom and cut up one girl cut up five
credit cards right there whoa plastic
surgery yep right there it was great it
said the classes are so fun you guys
they really are whether you do it
virtually or in person it's a it's a
great Community there's always good
discussion people can ask questions uh
you walk through the lesson together and
I mean it's uh it really is it's worth
it and if you do one of the the
personality ones were cramming all nine
lessons in about three and a half weeks
so there's two lessons per week it's a
mini term yes so it's real so it's quick
so if you want to kind of get through it
um versus doing the lessons you know
once a week and kind of keeping that
Rhythm uh it's another option so come
join there's there's a magic when people
do things together versus just trying to
do them on their own so this is a
community experience not a digital
experience it has digital elements to it
but you're gonna change your life if you
lean into this we'll show you how
ramseysolutions.com check it out all
right Millie's with us in Chattanooga hi
Millie welcome to the Ramsay show
good afternoon Dave
what's up
I have uh less than the two-year show uh
from the first time that you hit the
airwaves
and your plan has worked for me over the
years I'm now 72 years old
I'm a happily retired in a beautiful
Mountain Home
I lived that free for years and years
and so it's just my kind of folks
sister uh it's just a great retirement
life when you are deck free and you have
all the money you need at retirement
amen Millie how about it and there's
some beautiful mountains around
Chattanooga to have a house on cool how
can we help today
well I ran into one dilemma and I guess
that's because my emotions are in this
one I always thought that I did
excellent making the accounting
decisions over my lifetime and never
stumbled anywhere
but uh I'm with us and uh so uh I'm
engaged
and uh the thing is that I love my
beautiful home retirement home that I
have built
and my fiancee uh he don't have the
financial means that I have and he lives
in a small little home on a farm
and I'm sitting here in 4 000 square
feet home with sun rooms green porches
you name it I got it all and he's in
1100 square foot little small farmhouse
um he does not want to leave the farm to
live in my Mountain Home
and stuff like that why wouldn't it he
gets you in the picture he gets you with
the deal
yes he gets me in the deal maybe I'm
just gonna have to kick him into bed I
don't know
Millie how far how far of a distance is
The Farmhouse and the Mountain House
and then keep his Farmhouse and he can
go there when he wants to hang out and
everything you can do weekends at the
farm keep both
but he has suggested that uh you know
that we live in his house and uh so
anyway he uh he wants me to or has
suggested now he's never asked me for
any money even though he has a small
social security income he's never asked
me for money and I've known him since
childhood he has suggested that I invest
for about 150 to 200 000 in his home to
make it the home that I would be
comfortable in you know what I mean I
wouldn't do that and so I can't see it
because uh I I keep telling myself uh
that's an awful costly marriage license
well I don't think that's necessary to
get married I think he's going to marry
you anyway because he's a smart man so
uh
now I have no children but his family is
wonderful to me so here's what I would
do his house is paid for right
yes your house is paid for right yes and
how much of an EST egg do you have kiddo
I I have over a million all right I
would just leave his house as your
weekend property y'all both hang some
clothes and others after you're married
had some clothes in both houses I got a
lake house about an hour and 15 minutes
south of my house and I love it but I
ain't gonna live down there it's too far
away and so but I'm down there most
weekends uh in the summer and a couple
of them in the winter and I keep a set
of clothes down there I just throw a
backpack in the car and I go down there
Sharon and I that's our second home and
you've got a wonderful Farm beautiful
little farm with a nice little house on
it that's your wonderful second home and
y'all go spend weekends on the farm and
weekdays up at the other place or vice
versa and keep them both but I would not
I would not improve that property it's
not what you want to do Millie that's
why I wouldn't do it because you don't
want to do it well that ends what is
does he have a quick reasoning to why he
wants to stay in The Farmhouse is he
just like being by the farm like I
wonder what his reason is well uh the
house was in 1905 and it was his
grandfather's and his father's home and
he would I would not get rid of yeah
don't yeah don't sell it don't sell it
but I wouldn't improve it I would just
use it as my weekend Farm home
well I think that what I the conclusion
that I'm thinking of right now Dave
since you mentioned that is I think I'll
just uh take one extra bedroom in it and
build me a large walk-in closet
yes when Millie's gonna hang some
clothes absolutely she's taking a
bedroom I'm just saying a hundred
percent Millie you're the most fun I've
had in a long time well done I love it
yeah you need to tell this guy to paint
her get off the ladder y'all get married
and use a farm as a weekend home and
just turn that bedroom into a walk-in
closet you got a plan this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
hey if you're brand new to this show and
a whole bunch of you are based on our
ratings increases and our ranking
increases and so forth we appreciate all
of you being here and of course if you
want to if you're you know you're
hearing stuff like baby steps and debt
snowballs and you don't know what all
that means you want to get plugged in go
to ramseysolutions.com for free and
click on the get started button
when you click the get started button
it'll help you figure out where you are
and what your next steps are and you'll
start to learn the lingo of the stuff
we're talking about and figure out how
you can best apply some of this and
start to change your life so hey that's
what we're here for the phone number
here triple eight eight two five five
two two five Brian's in New York City
hey Brian how are you
hey Dave Rachel uh pleasure to speak
with you thanks for taking the call sure
what's up
um so my wife and I are out of debt
um we built up our fully funded
emergency fund and we're in baby step 3B
um we are currently renting
um we're about an hour away from the
city so
um and we commute into the city to work
and we're trying to save up for a down
payment and we're doing we're trying to
cut corners and take every step we can
to
um increase the amount that we can save
each month and I'm just wondering if I
should change my retirement down to zero
and what my wife should do with her
percentage at work currently I'm working
part-time and I'm also staying at home
with the kids so we're cutting out child
care there and she works as a nurse
manager and full-time and her job has a
four percent match at 50 I mean I'm
sorry a 50 match and she currently has
at four percent
so I'm just not sure what we should be
doing to
try to get the most amount possible and
uh if just trying to figure out ways to
yeah have you guys
um kind of done a timeline Brian to say
hey if she does pause because I would I
would encourage you guys to pause for a
period of time while you're saving just
to increase the cash flow like what
you're what you're mentioned what you
mentioned do you know how long it would
take you guys to save up a down payment
if you guys paused all retirement and
threw all the extra money you guys have
per month
um it's probably going to be a couple
years currently we have
um
6 000 down payment we have 5 000 in a
car fund and I guess if need be we can
combine them
um but yeah to get a good down payment
uh especially in this area uh it's going
to take a couple years at least
how old are you
I am 31 and my wife's birthday is
actually today and she is not going to
say okay so if you started saving for
retirement
at 15 of your household income
beginning at age 33 you would retire a
multi-millionaire
okay and so if you take two years off
and save up a down payment and then you
start the trick is don't take two years
off and then keep spending like you're
in Congress you don't need to be going
out to eat we're saving for a house we
don't need to be going on vacation we're
saving for a house we're saving for a
house we're set we're sacrificing the
match we're sacrificing the compound
interest we're sacrificing our
investments to get a house so by god
let's get the house
don't screw around the edges of this you
see what I'm saying
you got to play through for this to make
sense if you if you just stop retirement
and then you lollygag along for five
years this is not good
okay so you're thinking somewhere in the
range of one to three years yeah yeah
three years will be the max I would be
unplugged
and so you got to set yourself a goal
and say how much have we got to save a
month to be there and what have we got
to do to make that happen
and that may be working extra that may
be cutting other things or maybe other
things involved but you got to set this
as a detailed thing because you do the
danger of some of the stuff that we
teach is if you don't do it all
it'll leave you hanging
because we tell you to stop retirement
and you know get out of debt but if you
don't go get out of debt then then you
and you never start retirement again or
in your case you've got your emergency
fund I'm trying to I'm gonna I'm gonna
really enhance this 3B because this is
an expensive area I need some down
payment money yeah and Brian too we your
first time home buyers
renting you know we say anywhere from 5
to 10
for a down payment so be you know
looking on that side so that you guys
can press play back into retirement and
then you're on baby steps four five and
six and then you're throwing extra money
that you guys have at the house but uh
yeah we love 20 down because you avoid
PMI but for a first-time home buyer
getting out Rachel's right let's get the
deal done yeah
um and uh you know five ten percent down
something like that you're gonna have
some PMI but get her done and then get
that retirement going and then get that
mortgage paid down and get rid of that
PMI that'd be your next thing Arthur's
in Richmond Virginia Hey Arthur how are
you
I'm good how are you guys doing better
than we deserve what's up
um so I had a question I've seen you
guys give some career advice so I want
to ask you um I I am in a job right now
and I don't think my boss is very good
at doing his boss job and um so I'm
wondering I really have some one main
question is how do I when do I know how
bad I have to get before I leave and
then also if you're doing things that I
know aren't aren't useful to his to the
people under him including myself when
do and things that I just think are
wrong when do I when would I go to his
boss and
um kind of report things I don't want to
obviously stir the pot and just like
start fights at work with with his boss
about it or
um cause problems at work but
um I just don't know like when is when
is the right time to go to his boss
about things that he's doing or lack of
or not doing and um when would I know
it's just time to move on and go to a
different company
Arthur is it is any of it moral issues
or is it more just leadership style like
he's not engaged where he should be and
he's not communicating is it more of
those kind of attributes or is there
stuff going on that you're like that's
flat out wrong borderline immoral
um so leadership style I can get over
but like one is competency in leadership
like
um I'm a salesperson I've been number
one in my company for the past five
months and uh some of the advice he
gives me I'm just like yeah I would
never do that like I don't I don't
understand where you're getting this
advice and I don't believe he has the
experience to back up his like his role
as also a teaching manager
um in sales and then have you been there
five months
I've been there about six months how old
are you
I'm 26. how old is she
oh gosh like 50 something
okay so what do you think the
probability that you talking to his boss
is gonna fix all this
uh
boss does ask me questions about him and
I'll give him honest feedback I don't
know what it's going to change honestly
I really don't well and I mean there's
two possibilities
one is realistic one is not one
possibility is they move him on
they fire him
because he kind of came to his job and
their number one sales guy is talking uh
to leadership about that okay
um that that's a possibility that's
reasonable the possibility that this 55
year old guy who is not competent
suddenly becomes competent because you
talk to his boss is precisely zero
okay
think about it they can't train him up
on the things he's doing in a short
period of time these are long pattern
things that have to be fixed
so you're either going to endure him
while he's growing
uh which is really doubtful or he's
going to be removed
um or you're going to be labeled and
you'll be gone
right that's something I'm worried about
well I wouldn't be worried about it
you're going to quit anyway so what's
the matter
so that's I guess the other question
then in terms of quitting
um like so I don't know like it's good
money and I'm making good money and I'm
happy in that sense but it's just it's a
mess all the time with like you know
management so I don't know I don't know
at what point I should leave because I'm
not growing personally except things I
learn on my own but I'm not learning
from the company anymore so okay I don't
know when
oh I I would I would have I would have
something else in place Arthur before
you go in and just quit though right
because there's sales jobs everywhere if
you're a great sales person you can find
a lot of things to sell and find good
culture in other companies it doesn't
sound like it's a great culture I think
you've lost faith in the entire
organization not just this one guy and
it's probably time for you to go get
something else which thankfully you're
you're Broad
a lot of places but go get something
else and then be aware
that you might be 26 and after six
months you don't know it all
that's possible too yes I thought about
that too Arthur a little humility just
this is the Ramsay show
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you love this
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsay personality number one
best-selling author host of The Rachel
Cruz show co-host of smart money happy
hour with George Campbell is my co-host
today thank you for joining us America
Lee is with us in St Louis hi Lee
welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Mr Ramsey
um I was calling today because I'm
trying to get through these baby steps
kind of on my own since my husband and I
our finances are separated and I'm
wondering if I should stop putting into
my 401k to get there faster
why are your finances is it Leah or Lee
it's Leah that's okay no no it's great
it's great I've been called worse oh my
gosh uh I'll call you by right now
um yeah Leah why why are the finances
separate
they didn't start off that way we've
been married for 14 years in August
and when we started out our finances
were together
but we fought a lot about money bills
were always paid I'll say that I've
always worked full-time but my husband
when we got married was going to school
and he actually went to pharmacy school
and when he finished pharmacy school
and started getting what I call like his
big money
we were doubling up on his loans and
paying those off faster
but the checking account was always to
zero and that he just couldn't take it
anymore and I couldn't take the fighting
so we decided together to split our
finances
but now fast forward that's been about
eight years and I'm still kind of
living paycheck to paycheck essentially
and I know that that bothers him for me
to say that but that's well it's kind of
a Dr Phil moment how's that working for
you it's not
it's not I know so Leah here's the truth
here's what we have found it's really
difficult
it's not that it's absolutely impossible
but I'm gonna say it is really difficult
to win with money long term and have
money goals like getting out of debt
saving up an emergency fund like doing
all the baby steps that we talk about
when you are in a household and you're
working on one income and the other
person is there with their income but
you guys share bills your names are
maybe on each other's debt because
you're married like I mean it's like
it's half it's half in it's half out and
so for one to go on this really straight
path and run really hard while the other
one isn't there it's almost like you're
just dragging this weight behind you
trying to make progress and it's really
difficult almost impossible to make
progress when that happens and so
honestly I would say Leah I mean the
Tactical answer to your question is yes
pause retirement while you're paying off
debt and getting an emergency fund in
place but that's
um that that's that's two three steps
later I think the first main step is you
and your husband I mean honest sitting
down and you guys really getting to this
point though where you
communicate obviously your needs your
desires what your fears were but the
frustration was eight years ago and
bring it back up because what y'all
basically did was just decided to avoid
a fight instead of get to a resolution
by just separating a lot of couples do
that well we just five we can't do this
so we're gonna just separate and just
ignore each other financially and run on
these two separate roads but the issues
are still there and they're probably
coming up in other places in your
marriage too Leah
yeah he uh we we still fuss and fight
about it because he's unbelievably
Frugal like he goes neutral down a hill
to save on gas
so he's paid off his student loans which
were very high like over 160 000 he's
paid those off he has an amazing savings
but I'm still over here like chugging
along paycheck and why is that because
of your income or is that because of
your money habits
I definitely a combination he makes
double what I make but we try to split
the bills so I feel like okay I can get
the bills met but then I've discovered
now through your book thank you I'm so
excited you're on the show today because
I love you and and reading your book has
opened my eyes to my own issues that I
didn't even know I had and I was like oh
my gosh that's me that's that's why I do
that and I didn't understand so now I'm
like
you know this Age of Enlightenment and
I'm like oh okay so now I'm like okay
let's make a budget and let's not spend
money on Amazon and let's not go out to
eat five times a week and you know so
I'm learning yeah um there's definitely
some Behavior stuff on my side but also
when I'm still trying to meet like all
the bills that we've kind of said that
we would meet together but separate it's
hard yeah yeah so the this overall
situation is not efficient
it's not good relationally
you're not resolving the underlying
issues he's not respecting your ability
to enjoy life and he's gone on with his
frugality so much that instead of it
being a virtue it's turned into
something you're starting to resent
uh you're paying more than half the
bills with less than half the income I'm
not sure how you figured that out was
okay
um and so uh you know there's just so
much wrong with this so the old book of
common prayer says this
for richer for poor and sickness and
health unto thee all my worldly Goods I
pledge
and it's this idea of joining our lives
because here's what happens relationally
and practically as well
you what you spend your money on
says what you value
and you value going out to eat and
enjoying life like Rachel okay Rachel's
mom on the other hand has six-year-old
leftovers in the freezer
she's your husband okay
they fell out when I opened the door the
other day and I said you're throwing
some of this out or I am it hit me on
the toe this has got to stop and so this
is this is how life works right I mean
this is marriage and so we're going to
I'm going to enjoy my wife's frugality
she's going to know that her life is
much more fun because I'm around because
I'm the minister of fun at our place and
I'm the spender by Nature even though I
teach this stuff every day and so um
I'll be the one that plans the fancy
fancy trip that she gets to take so
you're that person and that's he has
that benefit by having you but he's not
getting the benefit of that you have the
benefit of having some net worth and
actual Nest Egg built because he's
freaking Frugal that's awesomeness see
Larry Burkett used to say if two people
like just to like get married one of you
is unnecessary
but you're not getting the benefit the
complementary of your complementary
skills and values instead they became a
reason for separation and Leah I'm
telling you too there's a level of
couples when you separate your finances
you're separating something that's
supposed to be unified yeah dreams when
you marry someone you are sharing your
life not in this like codependent way of
you know all that like you still are
Leah and he is still him and that's that
was to Dave's Point earlier like you're
still going to be who you are but when
you separate that and you guys don't
work together with your finances I'm
telling you there's stuff that you guys
are avoiding and you end up being
roommates that there's a level of
intimacy that is created and
vulnerability when you say I I
everything I have is yours everything
you have is mine and we're a team we're
married like it should be us against the
world and instead you're in this like
triangle with the world trying to dance
around it and it's exhausting so your
marriage will be Thrive will be so much
richer and deeper if you guys work on
the same team so that what's the next
conversation we're going to give you a
Financial Peace University I want the
two of you together to go through it I'm
going to give it to you as a gift if
that doesn't solve it get in marriage
counseling
for the good of your relationship and
your future
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
things back
my guarantee and shipping is always free
see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today our question of the day
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services if you're moving you have
a long list of to-do's but neighborly as
local Pros like house Master five-star
painting window Genie and Junk King to
check items off that list visit
neighborly.com to schedule Home Service
Experts near you and today's question
comes from Wayne in Pennsylvania right
now what would be the best investment in
stocks to invest in if there's a
downturn coming if the government does
not raise the debt ceiling in June and
we go into a recession what is the best
thing to do with our money hmm
uh well Wayne I mean I would say the I
mean honestly we're still so consistent
regardless of what downturn is happening
especially when it comes to investing if
you are out of debt with a fully funded
emergency fund
you still want to be investing I mean
even in a downturn and especially in the
downtown yeah we've we've had ups and
downs and what happens a lot of people
have a lot of fear and they freak out
and so they either stop investing or
they pull their money out at the bottom
which is actually the best time to
invest because then you get to ride all
the gains when it goes back up and so I
would be very consistent Wayne on what
you're doing I mean you know we talk
about retirement a lot 401ks uh Roth
IRAs you know good mutual funds within
those and and just continue the path now
you know if you are in a position and
you know with a recession I mean the job
market and stuff you know that's
sometimes where you see
um significant possible layoffs and that
kind of thing so if you're in an
environment a company or an industry
that layoffs are happening and you have
a three-month emergency fund maybe I
would probably pump it up to six you
know you can be conservative on the same
on the savings end to get to money but
other than that I mean I would I would
keep investing but in June is when the
debt ceiling Dave comes into comes into
effect and so there's that whole
conversation going on and so when you
look at that
what are what are your thoughts around
all that I yawn
it's happened so many times in my 62
years
that they get up to them and they're
just gonna raise it right I mean what
are they going to do yeah I know of
course they're going to raise it like a
hundred percent of the time they raise
the debt ceiling because they just can't
keep quit spending they spend like
they're drunk and on drugs I mean they
just spend all the time up there and so
they're gonna race it of course they're
going to raise it but there's going to
politically posture around and act like
it's somebody's fault it's not
somebody's fault it's your fault and my
fault because we elected those idiots
and we keep sending them up there and
they keep doing the same stupid butt
stuff over and over and over again
they're gonna raise it and even if they
don't for three weeks and they have to
set some federal workers aside or some
kind of crap like that like they do a
time or two I can remember I think it's
happened twice or three times in my life
but every so often we get this thing but
it's Democrats versus Republicans and
I'm going to push through my little
agenda in order to not hold I'm going to
hold the nation hostage so I can get my
little little political crap into the
bill and that's what we're doing and
that's what we're seeing up there right
now at this moment yeah as always so
they're going to pass it and and even if
they don't it's not going to throw the
nation into a recession where'd you get
that that's just wrong it's not going to
do that so all of that aside question is
yeah your core question is what do we
invest in I invest in four types of
Mutual Funds growth growth and income
aggressive growth and international I
prefer mutual funds that have at least a
10-year track record and all of the ones
I currently own do and uh and I invest
in those in up times and down times in
all times I never stop I never stop I
never stop I invest all the way down I
invest all the way up I am always
looking like I'm the smartest person on
the planet and the only intelligent
thing I did was I didn't stop and I just
keep investing and I just keep investing
and I just keep investing and we found
all kinds of research that says the
number one correlating factor to people
who build wealth investing is that they
act
they don't sit and discuss whether the
debt ceiling is going to knock them out
or whether the dollar is going to get
blown up or whether the chimney oh the
dead gum drama that goes around the
economy all the time okay well the other
drama piece you mentioned it but the
word recession it's bad I mean it's it's
a it's one that's floated around for a
while and a lot of people are saying
something that you can sort of
consecutive quarters of the GDP going
down that's a recession
but it's a little different different
definition if you say it with Movie
music in the background
a recession recession report live on CNN
or Fox
it's the recession we're following the
recession and then it
didn't actually happen
it's kind of anticlimactic you know and
so or the recession happens and the
economy was down one quarter of one
percent
two consecutive
quarters
and so it's technically a recession that
totals a half a percent of shrinkage
I mean really
I can tell you something that had a
whole lot more effect on it its name was
fauci okay he had a lot more impact on
your economy and on your dad gum the
mess that you call inflation now the
inflation crap is real but recession
yeah guys listen there's always a
newscaster whose job is to scare your
butt because you don't watch unless
you're mad or scared
and if you're mad or scared not true you
go down the rabbit hole and keep
watching and keep watching and keep
watching and you study all the theories
and all the reasons that everything that
we've worked for is just going to
evaporate and we're all going to die and
this trauma this fear porn is just real
I'm not making fun of Wayne I'm making
fun of me and Rachel and everybody else
we all do this we all do this you're the
conspiracy theory Queen of the family of
course so you know we all do this and so
you get you just you sucked into this
you get sucked into this Freudian
negative scarcity fear-based stuff and
it keeps you the reason I'm going off on
it is it keeps you from investing yes
yes you have to just it's an act of your
will it's an act of your intellect I'm
just going to keep investing and the
ones that never stop for any reason they
just keep investing they're the tortoise
and they win every time I read the book
good stuff Jordan's with us in
Sacramento hey Jordan welcome to the
Ramsay show
hi thank you
thank you my call I'm
well we're honored how can we help
um okay so basically
um my husband and I are in baby step
number two and his brother in October is
having a wedding and he lives all the
way in Boston so my husband and I have
like done the mess and we're just kind
of getting like a little bit of anxiety
about it because we really feel like
obviously we can't afford it because we
have did it
um but at the same time my husband just
feels really bad because it's his
brother
so it's like
but at the same time when we look at our
goals of like starting a family and
things like that
um we kind of feel like we just need to
make the decision of not going uh but
then again because it's his brother
there's just that factor of feeling
really guilty about it yeah for sure
well
um I would say when events like this
happen because a lot of people you know
whether it's weddings or 50th
Anniversary celebrations right I think
it's looking at the people in the
relationship at this point and just
saying hey how how important is this
relationship but I'm not saying this is
your brother's case but just say like
they don't really have what what if
right they
they didn't really have a relationship
They Don't Really they don't
they don't talk anything I I still
Jordan would would caution you when it's
when it's immediate family I'm like
I don't think I would miss my sister or
my brother's wedding I don't think I
would and so even though you're in baby
step two uh for me this is where I would
probably pause and
pile up some money get a cheap flight
from Sacramento to Boston and sleep in
your husband's old bedroom that he grew
up in yeah
and turn around and come back home
cheap it out don't miss your brother's
wedding
but do it on the absolute cheap
if it was your friend's wedding no
you're gonna miss it
because 25 years from now they're not
going to be your friends it's your
absolute
25 years from now they're not gonna be
your friend they're not you're not even
gonna know who they are
you're not but I'll tell you
there's from now he's still gonna be
your brother so yeah okay I would I I
definitely I wouldn't miss this not even
a chance but cheap on the cheap the
absolute cheap hey Rachel I gotta show
you we can talk about it on I agree and
I have thoughts I have thoughts we gotta
go break
[Music]
foreign
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us America Rachel
Cruz Ramsay personality is my co-host
today
as a Spender
Rachel you've been known to buy things
like pizza
yes I do I do pizza I love going out to
eat so whenever I have extra cash on
hand uh it's it is absolutely the best
that's why I'm so excited to announce
our Ramsay cash giveaway it is back and
this is your chance to win up to 500 or
the three thousand dollar grand prize so
guys it is so easy to enter all you have
to do is go to ramseysolutions.com
giveaway and you can increase your
chances by winning by winning of winning
by entering daily so there's no purchase
necessary but you must be 18 or older to
win and we're not stuffing there we are
actually running one of our famous
incredible sales the ten dollar sale is
here so get the books and the tools you
need to build wealth find the career
that you were made for improve your
mental health and deepen your
relationships the ten dollar sale
includes all questions for humans
conversations from Dr John zaloney and
in my book know yourself know your money
and Dave Ramsey's newest best-selling
book baby steps millionaires and all
those deals will be gone soon so make
sure to shop the 10 sale today at
ramseysolutions.com John's in Chicago
hey John welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
oh my uh wife of 10 and a half years
passed last April oh my um five-year uh
cancer battle
like a year ago April or just the other
day
just the other day a month ago I'm sorry
how old was she
uh 37. oh
what was her name
uh Mary Mary I'm so sorry
thanks I appreciate it you said you've
been married 10 years
yeah and she's been fighting this five
yep wow you guys got kids
three uh nine eight and six
how'd they do it another girl
um we're getting by did I die one day at
a time yeah
so sorry John thanks
it's been a battle how can we help today
so uh we had been going through the baby
steps uh you know we really took a look
in the mirror about four years ago
um we were saying about a 92 a thousand
normal debt everything and and anything
um we've got it down to about 30.
um and that was a home equity and then
we still have about 260 on our mortgage
um and
you know now everything is coming we you
know we're fortunate we did it when our
first son was born we got life insurance
and I'll be having you know that money
trickling in really soon
and I'll have her pension payout or
survivor benefits and her pension
reimbursement check coming in the next
couple of weeks and I'm gonna have all
this and I just I don't know what to do
with it and where I should do anything
do I pay down the mortgage do I what do
I do what's the grand total
um with everything that we're doing uh
as state check for my dad my dad passed
about nine months ago
um I'll have about 600
to work with okay
um
well the first thing you need to do is
and we always recommend this is just
give yourself lots of room
for grief
because
um when someone's going through what
you're going through your your brain
doesn't work good if something happened
to sharing my brain wouldn't work good
I mean it just it clouds it just clouds
you you're you're you know everything's
going good for one minute the next
minute a wave hits you you know what I
mean oh yeah yes absolutely and
sometimes like catches you off guard
almost and
um you see some color or something you
know I mean any little thing can trigger
so just give yourself some space to cry
and that's okay that's not bad that's a
human thing and you need to give your
room so for him to do that so I try to
make as few
big decisions
as I can make and make them slowly as I
can make them so the good news is
there's nothing pushing you here
what types of decisions could you make
that you would mess up well you could
invest in the wrong thing
because you're you're critical thinking
skills to look at an investment or not
at the top of their game right now so I
would not do any big time complicated
investing
so instead I would just park it in a
high yield savings account or a CD for
six months and cry okay
um but I would pay off that he that he
lock you know a little thirty thousand
dollar might reach over and pay off the
house
uh did she pass in the hospital or at
home
at home okay I hope she was home for
about a month on the hospice okay yeah
wait are you John do you think will you
be in that home long term do you think
do you see yourself staying there
I want to I love our neighborhood I love
our house yeah
um I love our area our my our oldest um
is on the Spectrum and we have great
supports around him out here in his
school that's great he's really thrived
in the route last season I don't see
myself going anywhere yeah perfect okay
well sometimes people need to get away
from the place
and sometimes they're perfectly okay
with it okay so I think I'm okay with it
yeah I'm not trying to tell you what to
do I'm just throwing out things here so
that would affect whether I'd want to
pay it off or not right I mean if you're
going to put it up for sale
um you know in four or five months then
I'm not going to pay it off but if
you're gonna keep it at least for the
foreseeable future I'd probably reach
over and pay it off so that used up 300
of the 600 if I did my math right
yes
and now you got no payments and no
stress
and and then we just park the rest of it
I wouldn't do it I wouldn't do any
investing until your head clears there's
no need to no big purchase no big
purchases yeah you don't need to do some
grandiose thing and you don't need to
make a grandiose generosity move either
okay no big giving at this stage and
wait six months to do a big decision on
the other 300.
and give yourself six months to cry I
can't I think it's logical and you
probably can agree with me even though
you're right in the midst of the pain I
think you can still agree with me that
six months from now your brain is going
to be working better than it works right
now
I sure hope so uh well I'm positive
and so you're not I I wouldn't be and I
do this for a living and have for
decades I would not be in a condition to
make a major financial decision
one month after Sharon's gone I couldn't
do it okay I and I'm you know uh yeah so
things like with that 300 John just
ideas again nothing to do today but in
six months you know maybe it's one of
those things you look up and it's you
know maybe kids college accounts you put
some of that money in there maybe you
guys go on a great trip you know next
summer a year from now and say hey we're
gonna go and use some of this and enjoy
it and do a trip you can have
places to designate this money but just
like he was saying earlier yeah they're
nothing nothing big needs to happen
though the biggest stuff would be this
debt if you wanted just to kind of clean
it up but even John if you wanted to do
nothing nothing for a few months
financially you're fine nothing is in a
rush here yeah yeah
okay
and hey man if we can help you anyway
you call us back okay
thanks Dave I appreciate it I'm so sorry
sorry for you man I have a huh yeah just
high yield savings and just park it guys
that's a great rule for anyone who's
lost somebody
you've lost a child you've lost a spouse
uh even sometimes a parent depending on
the situation even a divorce I mean
anything that that has a level of that
grief trauma yes a traumatic event or
anything like yeah just give yourself
some room you got to remember personal
finance is 80 Behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge the mathematics necessary to
become wealthy are sixth grade math
but the critical thinking skills to keep
yourself from doing something stupid
are grown-up stuff
that's called maturity emotional
stability spiritual maturity
spiritual stability relational maturity
relational stability those are higher
indicators of your ability to build
wealth then you have some kind of then
you being some kind of math savant in
other words navigating life
while you do money is a bigger deal than
actually doing math
and so that's you got to have some
things like when you're in a traumatic
situation
pause and breathe this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
thank you
retro Cruz Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Charles is with us on the
Ramsey Show hey Charles in Boston how
are you
good how are you doing today better than
I deserve how can we help
uh yeah so my question today I'm a bit
of like a trust fund baby type of
situation and uh my question has to do
with I'm helping my girlfriend with some
of her expenses here and there
it's never that much and I'm kind of
overall engaged injury and all that so I
guess my big question is how much should
I really do
for a girlfriend
yeah
um nothing
that's your honest advice just kind of
yeah she's fine
y'all aren't married I mean you're not
even engaged y'all are dating and that's
awesome and uh if you take her out on a
date you can buy dinner
yeah but yeah I always but you don't
need to be paying her freaking rent
I guess that's a good thing more it was
really about uh different trips honestly
trips yeah I want to go on as well
um
so you know should I be
paying for any of that type of thing or
do you think that's just a bad decision
um
so tell me about being a trust fund baby
what does that mean
um you know so my parents kind of set up
like a trust for me when I was a child
so how old are you now
um but I'm 25 now okay and what do you
do for a living
uh I do sales
okay what do you make
uh about 80 I'm not you live on that or
do you spend more than that
um I usually live on in fact over a past
few years since I graduated I've been so
you don't utilize the money from the
trust for your life at this stage
I've never withdrawn from it okay
because a trust fund baby generally
means a useless human being who does
nothing because his parents left him too
much money
okay that's not that's not you you're
industrious you have a job you're doing
well you're living on your own income
and the trust is just a uh it's extra
gravy on the biscuit it's just extra
wealth and that's not a trust fund baby
I mean you are a baby they got a trust
but that's not a but the the trust fund
baby thing is a negative connotation
does that make sense
yeah and you're not that guy
yeah you're a guy who earns his own keep
and your grandpa and your your dad and
your mom would be proud of you right
yeah okay yeah okay so date a woman like
that
okay not one that's uh financially needy
as a single girl
yeah that I mean it's just honest things
with that and it's just kind of dragging
yeah so I mean does she work
yeah she works as well okay so why can
she not pay her part of
her life if y'all go on a trip or
something
yeah she just she doesn't have like any
disposable income at this point so what
does she make
um 55.
okay well you got disposable income at
80.
so interesting
yeah I I you know you can look at this
but you just need to be real careful of
it because I got to tell you every
dollar you put into something like this
has a tendency a negative weight on the
relationship you start skewing the
relationship when you're not both coming
at the relationship from strength
financially spiritually character
everything it's very hard to get an
equilibrium
that's an old guy talking
no that does make a lot of sense
honestly yeah and I would say too
Charles you where you could tend to
overspend because I do want to applaud
you that you're living within your means
of the income that you have and I think
that's gonna do you really well with the
level of dignity and what that's going
to do for you as as a person right I'm
like just because you've come from
wealth you're still standing on your own
two feet and I think that is going to
breed a lot of great characteristics and
who you become uh as your life unfolds
saying all that I think When Love is in
the picture and this girlfriend that you
really like and you guys think of like
oh my gosh we could go on this awesome
trip and how fun would that be that's
where overspending and emotions come
into play so there's almost a level of
accountability even for you to be like
okay yeah here's a great trip that we
want to take
um but I'm I'm paying for my stuff she's
gonna pay for her so that's even going
to dictate the type of trip we take it
may not be as nice of a trip if I if I
pay for it all right and so there's
almost this level where you can tend to
overspend in lifestyle in the name of
yeah we're gonna just go and have fun
and live life and all that so there's
there's something to be said about
having that boundary with yourself of
you pay for your stuff now we're just
making you process it like an adult
instead of a child
you just process have to process the
decision like a grown-up and when you do
that it's going to lead you to really
smart decisions here or smarter
decisions good question thank you for
joining us Jeff is in Tampa hi Jeff
welcome to the Ramsay show
thank you uh Dave uh I'll preface this
call after listening to callers back but
I lost my wife of 47 years uh 30 days
ago she died of cancer oh my gosh yeah
in our home was meat she was in my arms
and our children at her side wow I'm so
sorry so yes let's just talk but uh and
I I heard everything you said about not
making the decisions but um
if I I could I'd like to present my
question to you sure
so I'm debt free except for the house
out of the 56k on it
um
I have some savings
uh in retirement uh in the 401K and Ira
and then I have about I have some money
in a business checking account that I
have not transferred in as income yet
how much
about 180 000. okay and how much in your
nest egg and retirement
uh about policies uh about
um
well there's one right now the 401K is
115 it went down it's only at 1 15 right
now and then the IRA is 90.
okay so you got another couple of
hundred there and then a couple hundred
in business checking 56 mortgage what's
your question
well
well first of all
have a specific being an I own a small
real estate company we manage properties
and we sell and list and sell well I do
my wife's not here anymore
um and so I want to buy specific rental
property and I can get it for like 285k
and it pays 2 000 a month rent and
um and so my question is should I try to
take that money out of retirement and
add my business from my business income
to it and buy buy the rental
uh or should I not if I take all that
money out I'm going to get nailed on
taxes so you're gonna get nailed in
Texas anyway because uh something else
is in an LLC in the business are taxable
in a calendar year whether you take the
money out or not the profit is taxable
okay
are you a sub s or an LLC
uh s yeah you're gonna get you get it's
all it's all passed through on calendar
year you get taxed anyway I face the
same thing that's how I know
so uh but if I understand you're right
you'd have to drain everything to buy
this rental property and you'd have
basically no money left
well
I would have no because I would have I
could take 85 out of my checking and
then I sold I have about a hundred and
then I would have the
um but I mean you have no Nest Egg other
than real estate right yeah I wouldn't
do that well after after paying taxes
you're right I have not have a lot left
and stuff I'd have to build it back up
yeah uh well I could pay my house off
I'd pay your house off and rest
and let's save let's save towards buying
a rental property that we can pay cash
for without just completely liquidating
everything to cause it to happen it
scares me that you're just basically
cleaning out all the accounts to buy
this one property
well I love real estate but I don't love
any of it that much yeah you got to keep
a liquidity position you got to keep
some cash
um in this situation I don't know how
much other properties and what your
overall net worth is but you've
obviously done pretty well but I I would
hold back on that as much as I love real
estate I am so sorry Jeff sorry you're
facing that that puts this hour the
Ramsay show in the books
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ERS of Ramsay Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where we help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality number one best-selling
author co-host of the brand new wildly
popular smart money happy hour with
George Campbell on Ramsey networks it's
a big time podcast be sure and check it
out hey we're here to help you the phone
number is
888-825-5225 Diana is in San Jose hi
Diana what's up
hi Dave hi Rachel how are you doing
great how can we help
quick question for you um I want to work
towards becoming a stay-at-home mom in
about two to three years
and I wanted to ask if you think I can
afford it and if it's a good idea
okay so where what do you guys make now
with both your incomes
so my income is about I'm a little shy
of about a million dollars a year a
million
1 million right and my husband's about
150.
oh wow what do you do
I'm vice president for a major
corporation
um
how old are your kids
kids are nine and eleven and my goal is
to try to be home for them during their
teen years
yeah
it's no that's why I'm aiming for two to
three years yeah gulp
you know you tell me you're making 50
Grand we can have one discussion when
you tell me you're making a million gulp
yeah but still possible Diana you can do
it it's just to figure this out it's
just like yeah it's just a lot it's I
mean honestly decision it's a decision
it's a lifestyle shift and that's it but
I think as a mom with three little ones
I'm like I get it I mean being at home I
think is
um
and especially if that's where your your
heart is being pulled it's going to
continue to feel that way and
where are you guys at financially Diane
I mean obviously you're doing fine with
income but like with uh debt House
Retirement all of that where you guys at
so on the house we owe about 650
000 okay
um on retirement I have about a little
north of 2 million
and then in terms of Investments and
cash about 1.2 okay okay so he paid off
the house today what would be the
problem with that
I could do that yeah you could
yeah all right and then we just pile up
cash and how big a pile of cash do you
want to have before you live on 150.
yeah what's the track he's on is I mean
three years from now what will he be
making
yeah okay
in San Jose oh
yeah cost of living but you can do that
I mean you can do it and you're going to
have a net worth of three or four
million dollars at that point
how old are you
48 well done great well done
yeah
I think you just say I'm gonna you know
we're gonna have this pile of cash and
we're gonna set up our lifestyle with no
Mortgage in such a way that we live on
175 without draining down the net worth
and I would start practicing Diana
because honestly the shift not just
lifestyle wise but even
just mentally seeing certain numbers in
the account that would hit on the first
and the 15th with your paychecks that
aren't going to be there I think there's
practice living practice living on that
for like six months and I would actually
pay off your house today and start
living on his income
as practice
now okay yeah yeah but with no mortgage
right yeah yeah if you pay off the house
today and you just say we're going to
set up a budget on 150 and we're going
to live on that everything else is paid
for and we're not going to deplete the
balance sheet to maintain a lifestyle
that our income no longer supports after
you quit yep
and then yeah you just make that make
that decision
um
and here's the deal too Diana I don't
know how you feel about this because I
even pulled back from work after my
third you know even with travel and
stuff I mean there was there was a
season there and still a little bit in
it where I'm like when I can be home at
certain times I'm going to be and so
that was a shift I made in my career
about two and a half years ago and as
high functioning as you are which is Way
Beyond me what you're doing but they're
they're you obviously have something in
your personality and your passions and
that you're really good you have a skill
set that you're used to using 40 50 60
hours a week however much you're working
right now and to go from that to zero is
going to be a shift not that it's a
wrong shift and you may love it but you
may even look up to Diana in three years
and when the kids are in school all day
you may be like I wonder if there's like
a thing I can do for a little bit you
know each week and and I kind of do
something here again not for the money
but simply for your skill set that could
still bring in money so I'm saying all
that to say you guys aren't going to be
at 175 forever and ever amen uh you may
be if you decide this is I just want to
be the I mean if you quit in three years
in five years after that you're probably
uh got your kids graduating
right yeah eight years from now so
that's that lifestyle I would think
about how I'm going to plug back in you
may never want to plug back in at the
level you are now but Rachel's right you
don't want to get just um
uh I don't know personality Whiplash I
don't know what do you call it but yeah
and you may and again you may transition
into that and you're like dang this is
what I've been missing and I love it and
I'm so present and that's and that's
awesome but I just wonder you because
you are a high functioning individual to
get to the level you are I wouldn't be
shocked that you know that you weren't
three or four years yeah that you're
like huh I wonder if there's something
else here I have ideas with or I I want
to use that skill set of myself again so
that's that's all I'm saying because I
don't think you'll stay at 175 forever
either so and you know the the other
thing is if you want to go back to this
world a decade from now
um you know late figure out a way to
leave yourself leave your uh you know
the camel's nose Under the Tent leave
yourself an on-ramp
without I mean without jeopardizing your
your goal of being home with the kids
but you know uh if you were in the
medical world for instance I would tell
you to make sure you kept your
certifications in place let's not let's
not burn the bridges right let's just
let's just take a five-year sabbatical
and then figure out where we're going
back if you want to go back that's right
leave yourself that opportunity not
saying you have to but obviously you've
got a tremendous capacity to earn
um and Diana I'll applaud you in that
because I do think you know that um and
again everyone's story is different
everyone's passions are different
everything but I do think when you when
you're at that level of income the
courage
to say I'm gonna turn it off I'm gonna
turn it off and that's what I said gulp
yeah and I'm gonna and I'm gonna be home
um that is that's I just applaud you in
that not many people Diana really
comfortable in your own skin in your own
value system and to say I'm even gonna
pull back my lifestyle because some
people won't do that they won't
sacrifice their lifestyle for an income
that they're making but the amount of
peace that you will have if you follow
that gut and this is what you feel like
you're wanting to do
there's a piece there that doesn't have
a price tag your life is going to be so
rich in so many other ways and so I
applaud you Diana I think it's really
courageous I think it's awesome if you
pay off the house today and you live on
for the next two to three years and then
you quit your job you're gonna have a
huge pile of money and you have done
zero damage to your financial year Diana
to be 48 years old I'm freaking
like let's make it a million dollars a
year so what was what was her position
she say hi president of something
something yeah yeah my president yeah
that's a position yeah you're the high
pressure this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Matthew is with us in Jackson
Tennessee hi Matthew welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey Mr Ramsey thank you for taking my
call sure what's up
hey Mr Ramsey I have a 16 year old
daughter that's just entered the
workforce and I want to make sure I'm
giving her the proper financial advice
that I was not given growing up
okay uh and she's 16
. yep she's 16. that's great what is she
doing
uh she's a Hostess for a restaurant
making about 11 an hour good for her
that's awesome
and is she doing this to pay for
expenses or car insurance is there like
a big goal for her that she's
working for or just to have some spare
money
uh I wanted she wanted to do something
to get out of the house and I said and
she also wanted a car and I said well
you're going to have to pay car
insurance so you're going to need a job
and she got the job she's paying her car
insurance and she's starting to we're
starting the baby steps
uh and she's got about and she's on baby
step three since she's got about she had
two thousand had an emergency come up
and she paid for her own money or car
repairs wow
yes I'm very proud of her she's she's
ahead of me on the baby steps very proud
of her that's impressive what is what's
her plan After High School
uh we are we've been talking about that
she's still on shore on what she wants
to do for the rest of her life I said
that's fine but we need to have some
kind of plan to get general education
going yep yep okay
well that's great well I think you know
Matthew one of the things
about teaching anybody about money is
kind of even going just down to the
basics that there are three things that
you can do with money you can give it
you can save it and you can spend it and
we need to be doing all three
all the time and especially at with with
children in the home teaching those
three Basics is really helpful because
that's just gonna magnify as she gets
older and has a career and earns money
and starts a family you know and and
life continues on that she needs to know
how and what to be generous with and
what that looks like what that feels
like how to delay gratification and have
savings and knowing to put some savings
away which she has done a really great
job at already and then to spend some
and enjoy it and learn some mistakes in
that area right buying things that you
realize man I shouldn't have bought that
but but learning all of that those three
basic principles is a great place to
start and so that's one place I would
just encourage you and then you know
even setting her up with a really simple
budget there won't be many line items
but for her to be practicing when that
check paycheck comes in put some
specifics around it on what where it's
going to go and what it's going to do
and give it a name uh so again it's kind
of just taking what we talk about here
on this show and
I'd say minimizing it some because it's
not going to be the dollar amounts you
know of a full-time job
but still those money habits putting
those in place early is is huge and they
don't have to be complicated but it's
simple things like that she can start
building the wise spending muscle the
generosity muscle and the saving
investing muscle even though the amounts
aren't going to be large they don't need
to be it's the it's putting that Groove
in her brain
you know we're starting to say this is
how life works and so my job as your dad
is to make sure that you develop these
muscles so when you uh get the
opportunity later to handle a lot more
money you're going to automatically go
to wise spending good generosity and
good investing and saving and you're
always going to be thinking that way
debt avoidance the only other thing I
would add to all this from a practical
standpoint is I'd go down to make sure
there's a checking account opened in her
name with your name on it where you have
visibility and you look at it with her
once a month and teach her how to
reconcile that and how to keep a
checking account properly operating we
did that with all three of ours and we
did the save give spend thing with all
three of ours and when they went to
college they had a set amount per month
that was their budget and they were used
to living on what they had and they were
used to managing their own checking
account I did not have drama with all
three kids through four years of college
each none of them called with financial
crisis
in the middle of college
because they had the muscles built to
carry these different things and Rachel
and I talk about that in the book smart
money smart kids it was Rachel's first
number one bestseller we did it together
when she first joined us here at Ramsey
after college and it was her being the
daughter part me being the old man daddy
part and but it's teaching kids how to
handle money and it's covered in their
on an age-appropriate basis and you know
you're doing a really good dad thing
here Matthew way to go yeah absolutely
yeah and Austin will pick up Matthew
we'll give you a copy of that book smart
money smart kids uh because it is a
great resource but I think what you're
doing right now honestly is great and
then she's going to have natural
questions like we did as kids of
questions about taxes later down you
know down the road and Investments and
all of that like after you get your
first paycheck and you realize they keep
a lot of it you learn to vote different
it's just good for you you know it
starts forming politics right what
happens
yeah I don't like socialism I don't like
it when I'm the one that's earning you
figure that out real quick you don't
have to be 80 to figure that out you can
start 16 years right there I do remember
making a um
PowerPoint presentation asking for more
money every month because I was driving
home and I remember being like I have no
I mean there's like no gas but I mean I
don't really have much and I think I
needed like an extra 50 bucks a month or
something and I did a whole presentation
was that in college or high school that
was College really sorry I came home and
I was like I need she has a PowerPoint
presentation from college yeah we did
PowerPoint in college I know but I just
don't remember this I yep it doesn't if
anyone if anyone you would have done it
it would have been you yes it works yeah
that's funny yeah did it work did we
give you more money yes you did okay and
I was like he is a sale you made the
sale he is generous it's a marketing
presentation look at them there yeah we
raised that whole raised it 50 bucks a
month and there were your life was sure
that is for a college student
yeah changes a lot it was back when you
went to college back when I was there
that's true that's true uh Zach's in
Houston hey Zach welcome to the Ramsay
show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call quick
question about investing okay
um with interest rates being the way
that they are our CDs day wise
investment option for right now no for
short term well for short term but in
short term is not an investment
short-term savings
okay investing is long term
and you've got to outpace inflation and
taxes long term you got to be north of
10 most of your life investing
and CDs aren't north of 10.
right even with a uh like a nine month
uh CD for why do you I mean what do you
what what is this money for
uh just general money that's set aside
uh my brother's been whispering in my
ear man CDs man they're they're going up
they're the way to go and the way to go
for it is
to get rich
I think just for short term is what he's
looking at not long term yeah I mean the
interest rates on CDs short-term unless
you have a short-term goal for them
right so what are you going to use the
money for six months a year when the CD
cash is out
for uh for my brother's intentions I
have no clue for mine it's just for me
it's just another way to to bring it
money just another way to get some kind
of return okay it sucks for that
okay we call them certificates of
depreciation because they don't even
keep up with inflation if inflation's
running 9.6 and your CD's paying six or
seven you're losing money you get that
right
yes sir totally understand and I I'm
sorry Whispers In Your Ear tell him to
get a girlfriend oh my gosh oh my gosh
okay but I would say
80s high yields money markets all of
that are it it is wonderful when you
have money in it for short-term savings
because it is short-term though yes
that's what I'm saying you want an
emergency phone I know but I'm saying if
he's excited about the interest rates
today with those accounts yeah it is
exciting versus what it was five years
you know four years ago three years ago
it's not exciting well it is when I have
short-term savings and I'm like dang the
storm you're not making any money but
it's better than one or two percent
better but I mean that's why he's
probably excited but for short term it
doesn't it's not a way to build one no
no no it's a great apartment money I'm
excited about the interest rates
money more wisely but park it yes for a
short term like if you're gonna buy a
house in September and you want to park
yeah so September fine that'll work
[Music]
foreign
well here's a fact about Ramsey
solutions that I'm super proud of we
have never laid anyone off
wow we fired people
for not doing their work but we've never
laid anybody off doing to not do to not
be able to pay our bills for the past 30
years we've been doing what we preach we
run a cash-based business we budget
for everything including having enough
cash to pay the people that we hired
what a novel concept
and so far we've been able to manage
that
so we don't cut you loose because of our
poor planning
when the quarantine happened and we lost
entire segments of Revenue
everyone stayed everyone got paid
we had the cash
and we made the survival move to keep
all of our talented people so while
other people are firing we're hiring
and we've got open roles in our
marketing our sales our technology teams
and we go home at 5 30.
if you are a coder we don't work you 80
hours a week you write code if you're a
marketer we don't work 80 hours a week
we go home
now there's exceptions when we're in the
middle of working on some project or
something but ninety percent of the time
I walk through the building if
somebody's still here at six o'clock I
tell them to go home
and we're not just a radio show there's
1100 of us here at Ramsey Solutions
so if you want to check out the
positions the Marketing sales technology
programming check out the open rolls at
ramseysolutions.com careers we'd love to
have you on the team
it's a great place to work people
actually care here about each other
about the customer and by getting our
work done
it's really good oh but but you need to
know we work from work
we're at work at the building in the
building we work from work so that's how
that's going to work
so ramseysolutions.com
careers check it out we'd love to have
you on the team Ryan's with us in
Minneapolis hey Ryan welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi thanks for taking my call Dave and
Rachel how are you all doing better than
we deserve what's up sir
I are currently working the death
snowball we've paid off our credit cards
and student loans and we currently have
uh AC unit we had it replaced in two
cars
um and my wife being a math teacher
wants to attack the uh cars with the
interest rate versus the uh cars without
interest rates
um and just kind of the numbers we all
AC about six thousand dollars with 3.75
interest one car is 11 000 zero percent
interest and the other car is 30 000
with 3.5 percent interest and she thinks
mathematically it makes sense to hit
that uh thirty thousand first and then
work our way down
um and she doesn't understand the uh
kind of attacking the smaller working
their way up and and all that so I just
kind of want your advice on kind of the
you know relationship-wise it's
attacking the snowball and um just not
convincing but just further ammunition
well earlier Ryan what were the the
other dads you said you guys paid off
credit cards and student loans how much
were those yeah
student loans um I was going on with
student loans about 30 000 credit card
was about uh eight thousand what's your
household income
175 000 about to be 90 in Fall so we're
about to get more money and I want to
make sure we're attacking this smart
okay well I think you need to we need a
pan back from uh the discussion of the
debt snowball for a second and establish
some different principles because when I
first started doing this 30 years ago I
went at it the way your wife does
and most people in the financial world I
try to fix all of our personal finance
stuff with a math solution
the problem is math did not get us into
this mess because if you were doing math
you wouldn't have all this freaking debt
right
it's not a math problem
it's a behavior problem you've been
buying crap you can't afford with money
you don't have to impress people you
don't even really like
I mean it's a behavior problem
and so you don't attack a behavior
problem with a math solution
she's technically correct on the math
part
but she's wrong
on how to do this and the reason she's
wrong is you need to fix a behavior
problem with a behavior-based solution
does that make sense right yes sir and
so in Psychology they call it quick
feedback loops
and a quick feedback loop is I need some
small successes to build my confidence
and hope so that I increase my momentum
and my energy and my commitment to a
process
and so in other words when you start
First losing weight if you gain five
pounds you're not gonna stick with it
but if you first start losing weight and
the first three weeks you're on the plan
of uh you know eating
um whatever I don't know carrot juice or
whatever it is you're going to do and
you uh whatever your plan is whatever
The Fad this week is on losing weight
you're going to eat less you're going to
exercise more and you've got this new
way of doing things and you're
intentional about your intake and
intentional about your exercise level
for the first time in maybe a few years
and you lose four pounds that that's
encouraging do you know what I'm saying
yep and you'll stay with it and so that
is a feedback loop you you did the work
and you got positive feedback
and and the more you can do that The
Closer you can keep those Loops together
the higher the probability of a habit
being changed permanently is and a way
of doing things being changed
permanently is because this is a behave
a series of behaviors that have to
change and then the math changes not the
other way around
so all of that to say you pay off your
smallest interest rate first I mean you
pay off your smallest debt first because
you get the success God I just blew that
that's hilarious and let me say this
Ryan pan bag
let me say this don't you guys as a
couple are on the same page of getting
out of debt so if you both have agreed
we've been so stupid we have bought cars
we can't afford we've had credit card
debt we win student loans like we are
done with this life of debt right and as
a family as a couple you agree on that
and then the next step is okay how are
we going to do it but the major there is
already resolved like you guys are on
the same like you you guys are working
towards the goal right like we want we
want people to be free from that you're
a lot closer to winning yeah than if she
said I want to stay in debt that's right
and we talk to a lot of people we have
this show that that's where they're at
right so I see that I'm like whoo that's
a big hurdle yeah so Ryan there's a part
of me too they don't listen pay off that
that 6 000 with the 3.75 that makes her
happy and then the car there's a little
bit of me too that I'm like listen pay
you're both gonna pay them off it's
smarter to pay off the 11 000 with the
argument that Dave just said and it's
exactly right but at the end of the day
too you know like you guys are on the
same team so get out of debt right so
there's a part of me too don't don't
like be in this massive fight day in and
day out
it needs to be a change of how you're
addressing it though yeah but if you
both yeah that way you look at it has to
change because if you look at it through
a math lens you're always going to lose
it's not a math problem it's not but
when they both say hey as a family we're
not doing this again like they agree on
that that's the first step that's the
first step yes but it's not the last
step the last step is because Ryan
here's what you have to do I mean the
two of you it's her and you both me too
by the way okay so it's like I I hired a
personal trainer to the I've got this
gym in my house and he comes over and
he's got a six-pack and I got a keg
all right
and he he says okay you need to eat
these three things in this order
and I go well you know I don't think I
think I'm going to eat them in a
different order
well why would I that's dumb you know
that just doesn't make sense
he's got a proven process right I know I
need to do what the duber said to do I
hired him to do it it's and you hired me
to teach you how to do this no they
didn't hire you I know they did too they
gave me their time and so um listening
on the show and who knows I'm about to
give him a book and then he's going to
go to Financial Peace So he hired me but
the uh
Brian you are doing great attack it pay
off the smallest one I don't know but
guys it's it's important though I know
through this and and no I'm not gonna
acquiesce on this it's not it's not okay
to look at stuff through the wrong lens
that doesn't have the success principle
to it and so if I look at what my
trainer says to do and I go you know I'm
going to do two-thirds of that
I'm not doing that other thing then I'm
going to get a a muted level of success
obviously this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture of the day proverbs 4 25
let your eyes look directly forward and
your gaze be straight before you Stephen
Covey said most of us spend too much
time on what is urgent and not enough
time on what is important
you know Covey had in his book
principal-centered leadership it may
have been in Seven Habits of Highly
Effective People to the quadrant of time
that you manage and four different
quadrants urgent and important
um
urgent important or see urgent not
urgent important not important yeah and
we spend too much time on things that
are urgent but not important let it be
like answering your email
you know or making sure you check your
Twitter feed
uh
the slave of the digital world all right
Robert is in Atlanta hey Robert welcome
to the Ramsey Show
thank you so much for taking my call
sure how can we help
so uh my wife and I have found ourselves
in an unsafe house we believe and so
we're we're thinking that we're gonna
have to move
um really ASAP what's wrong with the
house there's some well sir we just we
didn't really do our research up front
we had a baby
um that was due within a couple of weeks
by the time we uh we bought it and so we
rushed in the upsize and make room for
the baby but the location just kind of
is is more unsafe you know we hear a lot
of crime activity going on around us
um you know gunshots every now and then
so
that's kind of the gist
what was the event that broke the
camel's back what was the latest thing
they went I got to get out of here
yeah well I think within the first two
weeks you know we had our cars broken
into
um I'd say I'm done so one yeah there
you go okay sell it get out get out of
Dodge this year live in Dodge City
I shoot up and down the street
right right yeah right that's it get out
of Dodge no pun intended but yeah really
do it yeah I mean and it doesn't matter
how much we sell it for well I mean you
don't have to panic
uh I mean do you have any money it's
important not urgent yeah do you have
any money might be urgent I don't know
yeah we've got about thirty thousand
dollars uh liquid what'd you pay for the
house
we've had 345. okay call a Ramsey caller
Ramsey trusted real estate endorsed
local provider for Real Estate sit down
with them and tell them that you want to
sell the home and what is a reasonable
period of time a reasonable price for
the house to sell in 60 to 120 days
okay and then the shot and the and then
decide do I want to go ahead and move
or or can I make it that long
okay understood can you make it that
long are you do you feel safe enough to
stay two or three more months or do you
need to go ahead and move now
well I we've we've been there for six so
you know six or three more months
probably could happen six months
right and two cars got broke into okay
right
right that's that's right yeah okay
y'all talk about it because listen if
they're shooting up and down the street
and they're breaking into my cars and I
got a new baby I'm gonna go rent go rent
an apartment and move
and put it up for sale and when it sells
I'll talk about buying somewhere else
but right now we may not even buy
just go get go get in go get your family
safe right you got to get out of the
freaking war zone
right am I missing something yeah
no the other the other question was just
you know is renting an option you know
if we were to move you know renting is
fine because we need to you know build
up some capital for the next down
payment and we can take our time to
calculated with the next one of course
yeah yeah but you know if we yeah is
renting an option yeah the current one
you know yeah to start with it's your
only option right now
if you move out this weekend because you
don't feel safe
okay so you're going to be renting a
while and that's okay but if you say it
we're going to rent for two years build
up cash and Slow Down slow our roll and
get a better you know get a much more
diligent
careful process when we buy next time
sure yeah I'm sorry I may not have been
clear I guess the current house given
that the atmosphere is changing that
area appreciation could be a thing in
the next few years and so if we could
hold on to that no no
if we have to move because our family is
not safe we're not counting on
appreciation
okay
that's just you live in Dodge City no I
mean the cool people are living there
but the cool people are not scared of
the bullets okay that's fine you got
hipsters next to gangsters I got it okay
but that that's one of these
gentrification neighborhoods but this is
okay you can do that but you told me
with the start of the call you have a
new baby and as a dad you don't feel
safe
so if you don't feel safe don't invest
in the area
okay 10-4 understood thank you so much
get out of Dodge man
that's that and also you know yeah if
you guys don't feel safe
then move like like your peace of mind
is is
very important in that way
that is living apart in Nashville though
that I mean there is there's a lot of
four or five areas on my hand right now
yeah and people don't live there in
their expensive houses you know what I'm
saying so and some of them are nice
houses and it's the top it's the
tolerance level of what feels right to
you so that's what I'm saying it is the
difference in a boomer and a millennial
I think so for sure
no boomers are going to live next to
gangster this and call it fun
Millennials think it's funny I don't
understand these hipsters next to
gangsters to me
it makes no sense
but it's everywhere I get it I see it
happening and it's the regentrification
neighborhoods is the nice way of saying
it but um and you know it and he's right
if it continues and enough people don't
get killed in the process then if it can
I also think we will be a huge
investment in Nashville in a suburb of
net like it's a we are we're in a suburb
yeah but I just say like we have friends
that have moved here from Chicago from
other areas and yeah you hide your per
like it's just like there's a different
safety measure of how they're used to
living life than we are so like I'm
saying your tolerance for all of that is
very low which is not wrong no but I'm
also saying to Robert we live next to
gangsters it doesn't matter
this is you keep saying that I'm like I
don't know I don't know what it is I
mean when they're shooting up and down
the dadgum street
and you call it fun I mean I don't get
this not you not you but I'm just saying
people some people have a higher
tolerance
for where they live and so but Robert
that's what I'm saying it's so
individual and if Robert and his wife
aren't comfortable they're not
comfortable the car being broken into
when they have a new baby that makes
them normal yes
that makes them smart yeah I don't hear
you but I'm also hey I broadening
childhood friends of yours bought house
door kicked in robbed the whole place in
one of those neighborhoods right after
you got married I remember the story
okay won't name the name we're on the
radio but the uh yeah this stuff it's
it's it's it boggles a Boomer's mind
I'll just tell you you I get it
intellectually emotionally I don't
understand why not go somewhere else I
don't get it it's a company lives in
there dude probably I don't know but um
yeah it just it's it's crazy and the one
the fun one have you seen the Nashville
judgmental map oh gosh don't stop no
problem we're moving on I don't even
know I don't want to know I'm nervous
I'm starting to it's making fun it's
making fun of us out here it makes fun
of every neighborhood okay and and so
it's an equal opportunity offender and
it's great it's like this one's gangs
this one's gangs that kill cats this
one's a hipster trust fund babies
this is Boomers like Ramsey you know I
mean it's like it makes fun of everybody
it's hilarious oh I think it's funny I
sent it to one of my buddies who bought
a house in one of those neighborhoods
yeah
so
you gotta have fun with this y'all gotta
have fun with it I I truly think that
that is that is a difference
generationally that I've seen that
um that is way different because the the
generations prior to mine and then mine
were suburbanites and they came to the
suburbs for a safe they left met yes
they either left the farm yes they left
the farm or they left the inner city to
come to a safe bubble and then the
generations following are going back
into those areas and regentrifying them
uh and living in them and that's what
he's dealing with that's what he's
dealing with yeah so it's very
interesting all right that's a fun
discussion Rachel Cruz always a joy yes
[Music]
that puts us out of the Ramsay show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]